Jameer house has challenged me now you
have to challenge me sorry for defining
the rules game start playing godly Apple
3d good luck also uh unestablished
reading okay I'll put put our games on
YouTube all of our games oh you're being
so specific
you're also reminding me because I
forgot okay
well good-bye again and hello to
darkness d4
I'll play Knight f6 I forgot to check
the time what 4 minutes 59 seconds
black 4 minutes 59 seconds ok so we're
playing five minutes g6 Knight c3 please
oh they should be for Bishop b4 NIMS Oh
time 3o a3 this is a Samish variation
they should have takes c3 check B takes
c3 um what's the cool line I'll play d5
first C takes d5 be fun he takes d5
Bishop g5 c5 and then trying to remember
it was Bishop c5 the move I don't think
Bishop c5 is the main move a lot like f3
is a move six age six
Bishop takes f6
to week six so I'm feelin me feelin okay
here Oh Castle short Castle III maybe C
5 C 5 C 5 is a very typical move just
structure the center Bishop b5 you play
Bishop g4 I could play pawn c4
I'm Bishop i5 the move may be specified
hey thanks for the sub short castle play
knight c6 maybe c4 first old c4 just
preventing white from taking on c5 they
should pay for ya and Bishop a4 so
Bishop c2 is coming kind of hard to stop
I could develop yes play like you said
d7 allowing Bishop takes fabric.you a
rook so yeah in this sort of structure
white really wants to play 24 let's play
Queen Queen g5 9 f3 27 Queenie 7 so I
just want to prevent white from playing
pony for Queen c2 mmm
if I play tonight at 6 I'm allowing 95
which is kind of annoying like Queenie
for Queen he for yeah we're gonna get
some endgame
room F C 1 F 2 c1 I've seen one so we
could trade Queens Queen - Queen take C
to room take C - ok thanks again to the
new sub or the returning sublets might
be 5 so this is actually a very
positional game Ruby one rook b1 so
there's rooks on C 2 and B 1 if I work
FB 8 I got Vienna's interest for wait
rook Earth orbits why is that not
possible
oh because my Rex I'm on you gotta move
to you so yeah I keep my rook on eight
because I want to play it fine fine and
then keep storming the h3 is kind of a
slow move okay - it's a slow position
thanks again to the new sub rookie -
what to do here Mikey wants to come in
let's play officer another son thinks
another son okay V to rook a to b - ooh
oh I forgot about that
I can't defend b5 another sub thank you
played before I have to play before like
what else to do C takes b4 wait but C
takes before another sub thinks another
son let's play a B
it takes b4 a takes b4 yes I'm down upon
another sub nice one f3 let's play rugby
5v5 King h2 k h2 another son thinks
let's play for I'm just gonna put
everything against the b-pawn I'm gonna
play Knight B AIDS to c6 ok someone
definitely gifted subs unless people are
subbing back to back to back thanks to
our gifted loves Kim g3 I don't think
that does thanks again I want to play my
quiche or h4 am I scared
I don't think so I'd see smack c6 white
three minutes 26 seconds black one
minute 43 seconds on a time no Jesus g6
of waking up 7 g5 coming next I got my
ETA what a move it doesn't do much them
no Jesus a g6 now Brooke BB for Ruby
takes b4 ok the Kings on g3 nights on g6
neither for checking decent Jesus it's
like the Knights far away from my from
checking my King which is good
g5 can come in any moment nobody to and
they eat - it's a good move
let's take Ruby three oh no not really I
wanted to take I wanted to take yeah I
wanted to take C B 3 C takes B 3 room
takes be breezy - okay - okay so I'm
still telling pawn because I know I type
slips King F 3 F 3 defends in Knights
the subs don't stop
rook C to me you don't know what that
does C 3 what three books C 3 repeats
here okay - thanks another son okay
night-night 4 kg 5 fruits g5 let's get
some g5 you months oh I want to bring my
Knight to e4 but that takes a long time
- I need to let's play might be eggs no
beard no g3 King e6 provide another 5
Ruby 397 mm-hmm Ruby 7 5 5 knight takes
f5 oh that's a good move I just get 15
serves oh well thank you whoever that
was maybe that was Neil thanks Neil
finally I said I'm losing pawns left and
right and center Ruby 6 check waits
cannot find King takes yes ok I won the
thing g4 j ug 6 you Jesus
what it was I do it 2-0 minutes 42
seconds King g3 King to the 7h 4 94 94
Chen Chuck King f3 rook F - yes let's go
let's go
yeah black is victorious let's do this
thanks for the game godly apple also
happiness
thanks again you oh I was getting
flagged I lived a few times there my
thing on the floor it's okay O'Neal
gifting 10 more subs thanks thanks new